veamos si podemos encontrar cuánto es el
límite cuando x tiende a infinito de x
cuadrada más 1 entre el seno de x
primero pensemos que pasan en el
numerador y después pensaremos que le
pasaría al denominador en el numerador
tenemos x cuadrada más 1 así que cuando
x crece y crece y crece y crece y se
aproxima infinito entonces que le pasa a
x cuadrada más 1 bueno parece que este
numerador se aproxima a infinito aún más
rápido entonces esta expresión va a
tender a infinito mientras x tiende a
infinito y ahora qué pasa con el
denominador bueno el seno de x ya lo
hemos visto antes el seno y el coseno de
x son funciones agotadas
ambas oscilan entre menos uno y uno así
que menos uno es menor o igual que el
seno de x que a su vez es menor o igual
que uno entonces este denominador va a
oscilar y que nos dice esto bueno ten
cuidado porque tal vez estés tentado a
decir si el denominador es
oscila entre estos valores y el
numerador tiende a infinito entonces
toda la expresión va a tender a infinito
pero ojo porque en primer lugar el
denominador oscila entre valores
positivos y negativos observa que el
numerador se convierte cada vez más y
más más positivo pero éste a su vez está
dividido entre valores que a veces son
positivos y a veces negativos entonces
estamos dando saltos positivos negativo
positivo negativo y eso no nos dice
mucho y en segundo lugar tenemos estas
locas a sin todas cada vez que el seno
de x es igual a cero bueno en ese
momento vas a tener una sim total
vertical y esta expresión en total no
estará definida entonces por un lado
tenemos estas asiento estás verticales y
por otro tenemos estas oscilaciones
entre positivo y negativo y positivo y
negativo con valores cada vez más y más
y más grandes y con eso podemos concluir
que este límite no existen es más déjame
escribirlo
existen y podemos verlo de manera
gráfica para que puedas ver claramente
lo que pusimos en palabras así que voy a
traer por aquí la gráfica de esta
función justo aquí déjame bajar un poco
la pantalla y ahora podemos ver que
mientras x se aproxima a infinito
positivo se aproxima a infinito positivo
dependiendo del valor que tome x vamos a
tomar un valor muy grande y después
tenemos una cinta vertical y después
tenemos un valor muy negativo y después
otra sin total vertical y arriba y
después abajo y arriba y abajo y arriba
y abajo las oscilaciones se vuelven cada
vez más extremas y observamos que
seguimos manteniendo estas assynt o
estás verticales después de un cierto
periodo y esta gráfica hace mucho más
clara la idea de que en definitiva este
límite no existe